[Music]  senators had record low temperatures  lately some areas low 30s high 20s this  cold snap has really affected one of our  show's characters I'm referring to the  overly tight Simon Cowell t-shirt  character he would here's the t-shirt  character several months ago during the  summer when he  yeah now keep in mind that was like in  August okay during warm weather well  here he is today the overly tight Simon  Cowell t-shirt in cold weather check it  out  [Applause]  thank you I have to say please go away I  have to say I'm with Tommy Lee on that  one something fell out is he back was it  no and they throw it out here what is it  yeah I think that's a crappy show do we  have  I think moss tombs are falling apart  you're like bring that out here  why don't you get you chose call toning  your coating you-